Where can I find information on stomach issues? It's not from my cancer. I have indigestion and gas. I don't know if I have food allergies.
Well, always whatever you're looking for answers to questions, you know, you're for sure asked them on the zoom call here, but always go to our blog.
So that if there's something other than you don't have to wait for the zoom call.
And on our blog, I have information about hypochloridria, which is the most common stomach problem in the world.
And hypochloridria, which is a decreased stomach acid production from the stomach cells, leads to long-term hypochloridria, leads to growth of an opportunistic bacteria called helicobacter pylori.
Helicobacter pylori is often called H pylori for short. H pylori overgrowth causes damage to the stomach and perpetuates hypochloridria.
And it can cause dysbiosis in the gut, it can damage gut, the gut wall. It can be the cause of leaky gut syndrome. It can be, it is the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide. It can go systemic. It's top five causes of cardiovascular disease and coronary artery dysfunction.
It's a common cause of other cancers elsewhere in the body. It is the number one cause of rosacea rashes on your skin and upper torso. It's a common cause of other skin rashes.
Helicobacter pylori is a gram-negative bacteria similar to lime. So chronic H pylori is very common. It is, according to the World Health Organization, the number one bacterial infection worldwide.
So it's very, very common. It's very easily spread. So if you, you know, your spouse doesn't eat well and eats garbage and has had stomach issues and ends up with an H pylori infection. It's very easily spread throughout the family.
And it's a bacterial infection. So it and because it is often caught in the chronic phase, often a person with chronic H pylori doesn't even show elevated white blood cells.
So, but it's not uncommon that I'll look at somebody's CBC report and see a slight elevation of white blood cells.
I remember normal lab findings of lab tests typically give normal lab values of total white blood cell count to be anywhere between four to 11 or four and 11.5 or 4.5 or 11.5 or something like that.
But the clinical functional lab values of white blood cell count should really be about 4.5 to 7 anything over 7 or 7.5 beans that you have an infection.
And depending on how it is, it may be a chronic infection. It may be an acute infection. So obviously, if you got a white blood cell count of over 11, you have an acute infection.
But if you have a steady white blood cell, I've had line patients with steady white blood cell counts in the nights that we just can't seem to budge over a long period of time because they have chronic line and chronic H pylori.
Difficult to kill similar to Borrelia line, grab negative bacteria as well. It can hide and disguise itself in the normal Laura, normal microbiota. It can go into a cellular H pylori goes into cellular too.
It's difficult to kill. So, having a rifle sheet is one of the best ways to kill them.
How do I know if I have that? Well, I have several blog posts on H pylori and hypochloridrius. So I would suggest you go and look at those and start maybe taking some courses of action regarding that based upon what I write in that blog post can always make it a point with me and we can go over it. We can test for it too.
So, looking at a normal CBC and complete metabolic panel, you can get clues of hypochloridria, you can get clues of chronic infection, but not specific to H pylori through those tests.
The H pylori tests that are out there are not super accurate, unless you have an active infection either in the blood. So there's three different tests for H pylori. There's a stool sample test.
And that's only going to show if it's active in the stool. There's a breath H pylori breath test that's only going to show if it's active in the stomach. And then there's a blood test that's only going to show if it's active in the blood.
The problem is it goes into the tissues and that's where it causes damage. So it's a common that you get false negatives. So we need that a person has it, but it doesn't, they're not testing for it.
So it's best to treat based upon symptoms. So I gave some detail in that blog post about that. And I think there's more information on that in the chronic disease and autoimmune courses.
Well, next part of this question is, how do I know if I have food allergies? Well, you test for it. So, and I think the best test for food allergies is the Syrex, all right, 10.
And because a test for IGG and IGM antibodies and a test for many of the foods cooked or raw because it depends on some of the foods have been followed that the protein changes if it's cooked versus raw and the
Syres sensitivity can be too cooked, but not raw or something like that. So it's good to look at both of those things on many of the foods.